[Musique]
tractage je me la poche oui si samuel
koch est ça que c'est au grand père qui
était après un montage devrait en
profiter pour leur dire que tu as vendu
sa maison pour faire ce voyage de m
c'est pas moi qui ai passé mon prof
c'est pas moi qui hérissent la
correctionnelle c'est pas moi qui suis
en train de [ __ ] ma vie j'en ai fait
des jours que tu me dit pas un mot
et quand tu ouvres c'est pour dire des
trucs pareils pourquoi n'y a que de la
merde qui sort de ta bouge tout le temps
casoni pour dégager
je t'ai rien demandé moi pour me punir
c'est pour ça qu'on fait ça personnes
punies personne ne sait pas ça je vous
êtes là pour toi une fois pourrait qu'on
pourrait être ensemble qu'on pourrait se
retrouver ses réussissent à lâcher leur
il faut qu'une calme ne vont pas leur
faire de mal au château ce jusqu'au de
chasse est sacrée pour l'été ou pendant
toutes ces années j'étais où pendant que
je connais
[Musique]
car les choses en face moment qu'est ce
t'as pas rater dans ta vie toi
[Musique]